مع اقتراب سخونه الموسم الانتخابي الطويل
في الولايات المتحده تلوح في الافق متاعب
قانونيه تواجه الرئيس السابق والباحثه عن
ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري لمنصب الرئيس دونالد
ترامب على صفحته في موقع التروس سوشل الذي
التحق به بعد ان صدته مواقع التواصل
الشهيره اعلنت ترامب انه يتوقع اعتقال
قوات الامن له الثلاثاء المقبل مستغيثا
بالمتعاطفين معه للخروج والتظاهر نصره له
لم يصدر عن الجهاد القضائيه الامريكيه
تاكيد رسمي لكن وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
التي تتابع دقائق التحقيقات في سلوك ترامب
وما اكثرها تتحدث عن قضيه دفع مبالغ ماليه
لاسكات عارضه كانت على علاقه بترامب في
مخالفه لقانون تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه
وقانون السجلات الضرائب اعتقال ترامب ان
حدث قد تكون له تداعيات سياسيه ضخمه
بالنظر الى سيطرته على كتله معتبره في
الحزب الجمهوري وقد دعاها لدعمه مع ما
يعنيه هذا من عوده الاحتقان الى الشارع
الامريكي لكن الاعتقال المفترض قد لا يؤثر
على حظوظ ترامب الانتخابيه بل يقول محامي
الرئيس السابق ان الاعتقال قد يقنع فئه من
الامريكيين ان الدوله العميقه تمعن في
اضطهاده وقانونيا لا تمنع النصوص المعتمده
في الولايات المتحده السجناء من الترشح بل
واداره البلاد من الزنزانه في حال فوزه في
الانتخابات ويواجه ترامب الطامح للعوده
الى البيت الابيض في خريف العام المقبل
رئيسا للولايات المتحده جمله من التحقيقات
منها ما هو مدني ومنها ما هو جنائي واخرى
تتعلق بالامن القومي ابرز القضايا المدنيه
ما تحقق فيه ولايه نيويورك وهو شبهه تقليل
ممتلكاته وتضخيم نفقاته لاسباب تتعلق
بالتهرب الضريبي والقيام بالعكس لاقتراض
الاموال من البنوك اما السلطات التحقيق في
ولايه جورجيا فتنظر في مزاعم محاوله ترامب
وحلفائه التدخل في نتائج انتخابات سنه
وفيدراليا يحقق مكتب التحقيقات الاف بي اي
في اداره تر امب للوثائق السريه التي كانت
في عهدته اثناء ممارسه مهامه وسبق لفريق
من المكتب ان اغار على مقر اقامته في
مارلاجو فلوريدا حيث استعاد عشرات الوثائق
عدد منها على اعلى درجات سريه وبعضها
يحتوي اسرار النوويه وكل هذه التحقيقات
مستمره خلف الستار ولم يتكشف من تفاصيلها
سوى القليل
[موسيقى]